now let's bring in CBS News legal
analysts that's Ricky Clem and Ricky
good morning listen all the late night
hosts are joking about it but many
people thought please don't settle don't
settle because they want to hear the
details of the case what do you make of
the settlement and as Scott said this
eye-popping number well
indeed
787.5
million dollars it's one of the largest
settlements or verdicts in a defamation
case in history this is a huge win-win
for Dominion you have to remember this
but Fox doesn't admit any wrongdoing
they don't have to apologize well they
don't have to apologize you know why you
go to court and hire lawyers lawyers go
to court in civil cases to win money
that's their job these lawyers represent
Dominion they do not represent the
American people they do not represent
democracy they do not represent Joe
Biden and the people who rightly feel
that his uh election was delegitimized
by Fox that's not their job were you
surprised by the timing I'm only
surprised by the timing that it took so
long we lawyers like to say that cases
shuttle on the courthouse steps
yesterday you had two things happen you
had a jury in the box and and the judge
had asked for a special Master to
investigate the activities of the
lawyers for Fox yes it settled but it
should have settled before those
depositions before Rupert Murdoch before
Tucker Carlson because we learned so
much in the deposition and that's all
out there and it's out there for
smartmatic right smartmatic 2.7 billion
dollar lawsuit not only against Fox News
against other news people and
individuals they have a blueprint now
they just have to follow the road map so
we know that fox doesn't have to make an
apology a public one do they have to
address it in any form or fashion moving
forward what type of impact will they
have well one might say that it will
have little or no impact on what Fox
News does but also remember this as the
lawyer there are other lawsuits out
there and let's not forget about the
shareholders the shareholders really
need to know why that case didn't settle
why it didn't settle a year ago and
where was the money being spent so it's
not just Their audience they're
responsible for okay so more to come
Ricky cleeman thank you thank you very
much